how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome back to the channel where we
talk about Marvel DC Star Wars and a lot
of other exciting stuff but today we
have some really exciting info about the
Thunderbolts and the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series including some
leaked photos there have been reports
that the Thunderbolts are going to be
entering the MCU and at this point in
time it seems very obvious and very
clear that they are it's only a matter
of time it's just when and how but it
appears that we now know the wind thanks
to the community and Marvel Insider
Daniel RPK so let's go ahead and break
down everything that you need to know
about the support saying that the
Thunderbolts are going to be making
their MCU debut in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series how they're going
to be set up to be introduced in Black
Widow go over these Falcon and Winter
Soldier leaked photos and talk about
just who are the Thunderbolts and how
they're going to be taking the place of
the Avengers and the MCU
the first quick reminder of doing xbox
one and ps4 giveaway all you have to do
to enter is subscribe with notifications
turned on like this video and leave a
comment down below I'm picking a winner
at five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers so no doubt right now if you
take a look at the MCU there is a hole
in it as far as a superhero team is
concerned there actually are no more
superhero groups in the MCU the Avengers
are no more at this point in time so the
MCU is in need of a new team a new
Avengers team so to speak and it appears
that the Thunderbolts are going to be
the ones who step up according to our
report from Daniel RPK we are going to
be introduced to the Thunderbolts team
in the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series now this makes perfect sense and
isn't that much of a surprise because
the Thunderbolts have been rumored to be
making an MCU debut for some time now
and Baron Zemo has always been a key
member of the Thunderbolts and even
though in the comics he has a group of
Thunderbolts that he assembles himself
the group that is going to be in the MCU
is most likely not going to be his it's
most likely going to belong to
Thunderbolt Ross now the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series may introduce the
Thunderbolts officially to the MCU but
the Black Widow movie is going to set
them up and again like I said it all
starts with Thunderbolt Ross oh and
apparently he's brought a guest we know
who it is the Secretary of State you
have fought for us protected us risked
your lives while a great many people see
you is here
there are some would prefer the word
vigilante ever since the Incredible Hulk
in 2008 Thunderbolt Ross has been trying
to get his hands on a team of super
soldiers that's why he's been trying to
track down the Hulk this whole entire
time so he can get his hands on his
blood and tried to get his hands on some
Super Soldier Serum and it appears based
on what we've seen from Black Widow
that's exactly what he's trying to do
and Black Widow is going to start the
Assembly of Ross's Thunderbolts and it's
most likely going to start with
Thunderbolt Ross himself as Red Hulk now
Black Widow takes place after the events
of Civil War Black Widow is now wanted
and therefore Thunderball Ross is
tracking her down but that does not
explain why we see him so de-aged in the
Black Widow teaser trailer there's more
to Thunderbolt Ross bein in the Black
Widow movie than just trying to track
her down and put her in jail he's
searching for something and he's
searching for something that we actually
saw in the Black Widow special look
these red vials filled with essentially
Super Soldier Serum and at some point in
time in the Black Widow movie maybe even
in the post-credits scene he's going to
get his hands on one of these he's going
to take it and most likely become Red
Hulk
Thunderball Ross is Red Hulk in the
comics so it makes perfect sense and
Thunderbolt Ross is going to be the
leader and he's essentially going to
start a Thunderbolts initiative just
like the Avengers and the first person
that he is most likely going to recruit
is actually going to be in the Black
Widow movie as well taskmaster
now there are many different
incarnations and variations of the
Thunderbolts in the comics but as far as
the MCU is concerned taskmaster is a
perfect fit and he'll actually be in a
movie with Thunderbolt Ross now some
people may be thinking while taskmaster
is going to be a villain in Black Widow
and that doesn't necessarily matter most
of the Thunderbolts have been or are
villains that's kind of the really cool
part about the Thunderbolts they're not
exactly heroes they're more of anti
heroes and if you can think about DC's
The Suicide Squad you can kind of
imagine how it's all going to happen as
I mentioned before there really aren't
many heroes around anymore Tony Stark is
gone Black Widow would be gone Thor will
be in space the guardians of the galaxy
will be in space spider-man's going to
be on the run Doctor Strange isn't
really much of a hero as much is a
sorcerer and a protector of the sanctum
sanctorum so he's not going to be going
around just fighting crime everywhere
Loki is jumping between different
dimensions and the one division series
is most likely going to take place in a
different reality so the only option
really is a band of misfits so
essentially the premise is going to be
Thunderbolt Ross goes and finds these
individuals who are talented and who are
gifted but are kind of criminals and he
puts them together on a team and he
makes them an offer he's going to say
that if you come with me on this team
and you'll help me do all of these
missions then I'll grant you immunity on
whatever crimes that you've done or at
least I'll take some time off of your
prison time so yes taskmaster is going
to be one of the main villains of the
Black Widow movie but it doesn't really
matter for the Thunderbolts initiative
so to speak and it definitely doesn't
really matter for the next guy either
who of course is Baron Zemo who is
making his return in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series now Baron Zemo
really is the perfect villain to bring
back for the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series especially after the
events of Captain America Civil War
where he basically tore apart the
Avengers including Captain America and
Iron Man and he's responsible for Bucky
being wanted by the entire world
basically right now he framed him for
bombing the United Nations and killing
the king of Wakanda at the time so he's
the perfect villain to bring back for
the series and as you can see here we do
have some leaked photos of the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier series and he looks
awesome here we have Zemo Bucky Barnes
and of course Sharon Carter now it's
really interesting
about these photos is that there aren't
any leaked photos of this scene of Sam
aka Falcon it's just Bucky and Sharon
which leads us to believe that Zemo
could still be trying to attack Bucky
so Zemo is going to be the main
antagonist of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series there's probably going to
be some other people thrown in there as
well as antagonists but Zima is going to
be the main one that is until
Thunderbolt Ross shows up again
according to the report by Daniel RPK
the Thunderbolts will be introduced in
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
so perhaps Thunderbolt Ross is really in
control of Zemo the whole entire time
where perhaps we'll see Thunderbolt Ross
approach seem out during the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier series but the big
question is if Zemo is already a
thunderbolt and working for thunder
blossom what is his mission
what does Thunderbolt Ross have him
doing where he's going to be the main
villain of the series because again the
Thunderbolts aren't going to be a bad
group together they're going to be doing
good things so I'll be curious to see if
Thunderbolt Ross is behind as emo
getting out of prison because as we left
him in Captain America Civil War
T'Challa
did not let him kill himself or get away
so he's definitely in some high security
prison and it seems like the only way he
could really get out is if somebody let
him out and really the only person that
could do that is Thunderbolt Ross so
we'll have to see how that plays out in
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
now again there is no more Avengers team
we are living in a post Avengers world
according to Disney CEO Bob Iger he
officially went on record and said that
in an interview we're living in a post
Avengers world confirming that there is
no Avengers team right now so
Thunderbolt Ross who was essentially in
charge of world security at this point
needs to assemble a team and there is no
more Iron Man but there is somebody who
was trying to be like Iron Man who does
play along a lot better than Tony Stark
did and that person is Justin Hammer
[Applause]
now again the last time we left him in
Iron Man 2 he was being taken into
custody as well so he's most likely in a
high-security prison and again who has
the authority and ability to get him out
of that prison Thunderbolt Ross and if
you think about it Justin Hammer is
almost a perfect member to have as a
part of the Thunderbolts he was already
trying to replicate Iron Man technology
that Tony Stark invented and he is very
smart
not a smartest Tony Stark but he is
still very smart and he does have access
to a lot of weapons and not to mention
technology technology that Thunderbolt
Ross could actually use because Tony
Stark didn't really play nice with
others he kept his technology his AI his
Iron Man armors away from the world and
made it to where he only had them he
shared things like clean energy for the
world but he never gave people his Iron
Man armor but Justin Hammer is more than
willing to comply especially if it gets
him out of prison and then all of a
sudden with Justin Hammer the Thunder
bullets have access to technology that
they probably didn't have access to
before knowing Justin Hammer and the MCU
it won't be perfect but it'll help and
then of course we have ghost who has
been reported to be returning to the MCU
in exchange for my soul they were going
to kill me they lied now the last time
we left ghost was in ant-man and the
wasp and she was running away with dr.
Foster so she's not in prison or in any
holding facility but that would not stop
Thunderbolt Ross from being able to find
her and with her phasing ability she's
the perfect candidate to be a member of
the Thunderbolts and an ant-man and the
wasp Janet Van Dyne did heal her a
little bit but she did not completely
cure her at the end she said we'll
figure out a way to heal you so since
she's not in jail and is not doing any
jail time right now at least maybe
Thunderbolt Ross could say I have a way
to heal you and I'll do this if you join
the Thunderbolts and if not I'll put you
in prison so if you think about the
Thunderbolts like I said essentially
like a Suicide Squad that's exactly who
they are they're a group of villains put
together to do good and right now with
no Avengers team assembled Thunderbolt
Ross has to figure out a way to protect
the earth from otherworldly and super
threats not just the normal ones that
typical people could handle but super
threats such as Loki invading the earth
with feyo's his army so for the time
being a core
to this report from Daniel rpk our new
so-called Avengers team is going to be
the Thunderbolts now of course that's
not going to be the full roster there's
probably going to be characters that we
wouldn't expect to be in the
Thunderbolts on the team but let me know
what you think about the people that are
said to be on the team so far do you
like this team and do you think they
could at least temporarily fill the role
that the Avengers had let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to give this video a like
if you enjoyed it and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU giveaway details in the description
down below and don't forget to follow me
on Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll forth